you've been tweeting a lot about mr.
Donald Trump and you have a theory about
Trump and I think you're a very
insightful man can you tell us what your
theory is my theory is that he's stuck
in the first chakra must mean the first
chakra now a root and sacral chakras
that have to do with four basic
responses fight/flight feed and
fornicate this is controlled by the
reptilian brain yes his reptilian brain
is on overdrive and he is stuck in the
first chakra he's stuck there his energy
is blocked yes okay where and tell me in
the body where does this where as this
reside is it it's hidden the genitals he
thinks that he thinks with his penis yes
you just described many of us actually
but to be fair but you're saying Trump
is his chakra is down there where his
opinions on justice is stuck in his
genitals yes yes no you you said that it
was quite clear the first time how does
this how does this affect him how does
this affect Donald Trump if he is indeed
stuck in his genitals he's incapable of
moving beyond the emotional development
of three-year-old yeah he is incapable
of being centered intuitive
he has no insight no intuition no
creativity no vision no capacity to
offer hope trust stability or compassion
so who are you voting for
[Music]
not for the donut push now no well you
say that in radical beauty you say our
outer beauty is affected by how we feel
on the inside is that correct yeah I
mean beauty is a feeling and what
appears out there is the outer
expression of that if you're wearing
dirty underwear even though no one else
can see it your body language your
facial expression your eye movements
your gestures may be affected by how you
feel right even though that's something
that no one can say even though some no
one can see that your internal state is
always reflected and do you see it when
you look at Donald Trump do you see his
outer expressions showing you I see
resentment grievances fear hostility
guilt shame even depression and very
poor self-esteem okay
here's it's just a random picture we
have Donald Trump yeah that's the first
Joker that's so he's yeah yeah yes that
is actually his finger is pointing yeah
that is the first chakra that is deeper
that is the extension of his penis
you're saying actually looks like
probably that tries to you know he's
been talking about the size of his well
he was yeah a couple months ago you
started outside now his finger gives you
an indication yes this is a very
fascinating conversation this is not
they don't have this conversation on
MSNBC or CNN I think we're breaking new
ground here it's I really do I think
that we have broken through in any way
at analyzing a combination of sex and
spirituality yes they're very
intertwined aren't they yeah I'm not
stuck in my first chakra am I you kind
of moved a little bit beyond that
I mean so I know have to run for
president
yeah I know like low admin are you
talking about of you know you've
achieved certain amount of success he's
still trying to yeah you know mr. Trump
is still trying to achieve success
tonight not the worst thing that you can
say to him is that he's not successful
right right that's that's hitting him
literally kicking him in his first
chakra that is what's you can beyond I
think
you